Remember When the Right used to love to
say to some on the left being offended
isn't an argument right you would have
these conversations where for example
during the era of uh of the gay marriage
debate such as it was you would have
this period where people on the right
would go I just believe marriage is
between a man and a woman and someone on
the left would go I find that offensive
and the person on the right would go
being offended isn't an argument and I
agreed with them being offensive being
offended isn't an argument
they are now doing the exact same thing
when they go that's woke crap we don't
want woke crap they are not making an
argument they are not addressing the
merits or the facts or the substance of
any particular position or issue they
are using a term that much like I'm
offended just serves to shut down the
conversation dismiss people's concerns
and disqualify uh their participation in
those discussions